we are with uh Sam sevillian Sam a big
victory for you especially with the
black pieces against such a powerful
opponent tell us about this game yeah uh
well he went to open Spanish again and I
he probably heard something in July I've
been playing in this term with F5 so I
decided to play this other line which he
may not uh which one is the line a
castle Bishop C2 F5 Castle Bishop c2's
F5 the one that you played against
Lanier yeah
uh yeah so I decided to play a different
line of course he knew it very well as
well but it's a different type of
position and you guys were blitzing out
your moves at this point one hour 35 for
him one hour 32 foreign I guess he
checked this very deeply as well he did
and right now he started thinking a
little bit
were you happy seeing that situation
develop uh yeah look after Bishop A2 yes
I think he started thinking here yes
uh yeah well I mean if you don't play E6
then
um there's not really any other ideas in
the position so rookie C A6 E6 28 yeah
and this was still your preparation yeah
well he played B4 and then E6 which is
the same right yeah got it so he played
B4 okay four E6 Queen d8
by the way I think the engines were
actually agreeing with you at this point
David speaks the first movie I didn't
know
um but I think take six is fine
so we were looking at the position and
it felt completely crazy right yeah yeah
tell us about the strategical and
tactical motives well the position right
now he has hanging pieces on the f file
you could have avoided this by moving
the bishop somewhere the G3 or D2
instead of Bishop B6 which would be a
safer alternative Bishop D2 yeah yeah or
Bishop G3
um but what he did is he was trying to
concretely
take advantage of the fact that my
knight on C6 is hanging with this queen
A2 idea and the point is if I take it I
was looking at this for a very long time
yeah take take D2 let's say Rook D1
queen f8 king G2 H5 and now he has Rook
62 H6 G4 and Knight E5 and family for
coming
[Music]
yeah this one is not looking here yeah
yeah so then I saw that I can play
Bishop G6 uh Queen D2 it's only move and
here kind of very important moment I'm
really happy about this H6 because if I
go Bishop D6 which is very natural he
goes Bishop G5
and my pieces are extremely awkward I'm
not sure how to play them so yeah chick
is a very important move absolutely uh
here he has many candidates but I think
he should play Bishop B3 with the idea
of meeting Bishop D6 with takes in
rookie six there you go okay so I would
probably play Bishop back to H7 when I
mean Black's completely fine here
because I have a good counter play on
that file I like Black's position you
like Black's position yeah
uh he went King G2 I think he missed
Bishop D6 uh instead of Bishop takes D6
very important line it's Bishop takes H6
Rook takes F3 King takes F3 Bitcoin H oh
I didn't see Queen
that's a photography 94 is coming yeah
this is even stronger that's very nice
very very nice
yeah he has to take on he has to take it
take and he went for the concrete line
which is net H4 Bishop H7 Knight F5 I
take take net E5 F4 Rook takes you off
and I think I understand what he missed
uh but that's because rookie five
obviously definitely has to play rookie
five yeah yeah I would play Rook fate
and then he was down to 10 minutes it's
already very unpleasant because I'm
threatening G5 here
yes just came over yeah and to play H4
in this position weaken your kingmore is
so difficult
yes yeah so he took on E5 with the F
Pawn of course I was extremely happy to
see this you understood that at this
point you're just breaking through yeah
yeah I think what he missed was after
Queen D5
uh King G1
probably King H2 here probably changed
too and I just said King G8 yeah and he
has no one okay yeah H for Queen C4 and
everything's falling
and if E6 of course there's Queen D6
check which is the points yeah and the
game is over very nice yeah
I mean that's an important victory for
you uh Sam to keep your hopes alive to
win the championship yeah for sure
you're definitely still thinking about
that what do you need to do to catch up
with the leaders oh well I mean I have
two important games left with Hans and
Wesley so I think I need to get some
good rest and sleep well tonight
absolutely right out the energy levels
are definitely playing a major role guys
any questions no just our
congratulations uh well done Sam and get
your rest